and something else new from the ocean to
the valley we've got lobster rolls this
morning Luke's Lobster is a restaurant
has a second Las Vegas location now over
at New York New York Lauren and Grady is
there live this morning showing off her
Seafood Creations Lauren good morning to
you we're asking for lobster rolls here
good morning you will have lobster rolls
John yeah Lobster as a Heather
with second location for Luke's Lobster
Luke Colton himself right here okay
let's uh kind of get into a lobster roll
here make some for the anchors over
there and then tell me about how what
makes you guys so special cool so step
one to making the perfect world's best
lobster rolls we start with a New
England top split bun
put on the butter roller
a little butter on both sides it gets a
toast on the griddle
voila TV magic we've got a perfectly
Toasted Bun here
um
next step we take a little bit of
mayonnaise
inside the bun a couple slicks
then we take a quarter pound of fresh
main lobster meat this meat's coming
from tennis Harbor Fisherman's Co-op
today
we are a vertically integrated business
so we work directly with fishermen have
our own Seafood Company we ship all
across the country we're in stores like
Walmart sorry like Whole Foods and
Sprouts yep
um and then lastly here if I if I may
assist yeah yeah you guys are gonna go
ham my favorite part is the lemon butter
get a load of this one
nice and a little dash of our secret
seasoning please secret seasoning it's a
secret good job nice
and there she is it's perfect it's a
perfect man lobster roll beautiful okay
do I dare do I take a bite please hold
this real quick absolutely as I drop a
little piece okay nice close-up shot
okay take a bite
mmm great way to start yeah girl get it
okay it's so good
share yeah you guys it's amazing good
lobster roll she went Ham on that
Lobster